there's only one thing I know about life
I know some things happen by chance and
some things happen because we make them
happen
I'm finally free oh hey slugger
here's my beautiful boy is everything
all right everything's great
you look really familiar I've seen you
before haven't I
uh berry a berry berry all right sponsor
some people are just meant to be in your
life hey who the hell is this Cisco
Ramon is a richest man in America is
there a better way to get to work than
by helicopter
Cisco uh-uh don't call me that I don't
know you string bean we're not partners
and we're not friends you don't know me
you don't know my life or something else
to each other where you come from aren't
we
this isn't your home Barry it's a mirage
it's already screwing with you and
everyone you love and pretty soon it's
gonna take me right down along with you
what should we call this brave new world
that you've whipped up for us I was
thinking flashpoint
the villain flash now who's the bill
you
day three of comic-con continues we got
our flash season three trailers so let's
break it down this all makes me so happy
so some of you have an idea of what
flash point is maybe you saw the
animated movie or you've read the comic
book arc obviously the TV shows versions
going to be different but they basically
changed everyone's alignment the
dynamics between team flashes changed
the reverse flash now kind of throws it
in Barry's face who's the villain now
and it's hard to argue with him because
it looks like he's been keeping him
locked up in a basement just like zoom
would you know zoom was a villain he
gets speedsters locked up and it looks
like he's actually been in there for a
while because he's grown a beard
reverse-flash beard most evil of all
beards and it seems like he hasn't told
anyone else that he's keeping him down
there so Barry really is something of a
villain when the story picks up but
obviously we see dr. alchemy I'm so
happy when I saw dr. alchemy very
clearly going to be Tom Felton's
character because the second version of
dr. alchemy in the comics wore masks
that looked just like the one that we
see in the trailer here and before he
became a villain he worked with Barry
inside the crime lab so on top of that
tom felton on the panel also like tom
felton was at the flash panel said that
any character that I play you should
feel threatened by so you know very
clearly he's going to have a very dark
twist really don't know how close his
version of dr. alchemy is going to be to
comic book alchemy but he's basically
someone who combines science and magic
so just expect the TV show to have fun
with that you know going from the Harry
Potter magic universe to magic on the
flash TV show which i think is awesome
but the next big thing Cisco is now kind
of like the Harrison wells like the
person who is leading STAR Labs and it
looks like in this version of the
timeline
he had more self-confidence where he
just decided to use his genius to make
money but either way it looks like he's
been working with Wally West's version
of the flash this whole time so he's
still a relatively good character team
flash is still there but it's just like
they all feel a little bit differently
about each other and one of the other
big casualties of flashpoint is iris has
no idea who Barry is and they also
explain some stuff about iris but you
can see now that it's slightly less
creepy for Barry to pursue her just
because they haven't been living
together this whole time they're not
really like brother and sister in this
timeline but the ticking time bomb like
the reason why Barry can't just get used
to this timeline is because the
reverse-flash said that it's going to
wreak havoc on him like
he starts having those flashes it's
plugging into something crazy with his
powers but no idea if they'll ultimately
resolve this arc like this season 3 arc
in the same way that comic book
flashpoint works because in this version
of the timeline both of Barry's parents
are still alive in comic book flashpoint
it was just his mother that he saved so
at the end of that he had to go back and
allow her to die like he just had to be
okay with her die
so if Barry's gonna get his timeline
back he's gonna have to give his parents
up by the end of the season but not
before we find out who this new black
flash is so very clearly different from
the reverse flash so I know there's like
a bunch of different comic book names
for reverse flashes the TV show tends to
change that a little so we'll just call
the Matt ledger reverse flash the
reverse flash so whatever this guy's
name is it's going to be completely
different when they did confirm this is
such a huge deal I'm going to do a video
about it tomorrow but legends of
tomorrow season 2 is going to be Legion
of Doom Justice Society vs. Legion of
Doom best possible thing that could have
happened the Matt ledger reverse flash
is going to be a member of the Legion of
Doom so I think we can all assume that
at some point this season he's gonna
break out of that cell that Barry has
him in but no idea how that's going to
work
we saw the four night crossover there's
an arrow trailer there's Supergirl
season two so I'll post those videos
tomorrow they're just like way too much
stuff to do today but what's going to
happen is is there's so much more
information about the flash season 3
that they've already revealed they'll
just try to do more bonus videos as we
get closer to the season so week to week
I'll just be doing flash videos like I
normally would I'll still be doing the
giveaway there will be more trailers
like this is just the first of many
trailers to come so if you didn't know
Flash's back that first week in October
it's gonna be an awesome season I'm
really interested to see what the
dynamic feels like I know it seems a
little like Joe's an [ __ ] like we're
not partners we're not friends don't
talk to me but you have to remember in
this version of the timeline he didn't
raise Barry and they explained behind
the scenes that he's estranged from iris
like they're on the outs and they don't
explain why that is like you don't learn
why that is right away so so so much to
talk about like today was an awesome DC
day there's a bunch of Marvel stuff
that's going to be dropping tonight so
I'll be doing videos for that too I'll
be posting updates on Twitter and
Facebook but congratulations to the new
giveaway winner Kevin Z you win a $20
Amazon gift card just be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I
your contact details there is a new
round of the giveaway that starts not to
like it'll just keep going so all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so new Marvel Doctor Strange guardians
of the galaxy stuff should post way
later tonight while you guys wait for
all that stuff to post you can click
here for my Justice League trailer
breakdown and you can click here for my
Wonder Woman trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight